>> My name is Bright Simons. I'm the chief
strategist of MPedigree. I am from Ghana.
The issue of contract with medicine is one
but clearly should receive the highest attention,
the highest levels of government the world.
As we have spent accessing medicines throughout
the developing world. The quality of the medicines
that we actually supply is of the highest
importance. Sometime in 1995 as many as three
thousand people died. Three thousand children
I'm sorry, died from being vaccinated with
fake vaccines. Therefore this is initial clear
and high importance. And the more that we
ignore this issue less likely are our chances
of then showing that the monies and investment
that we are putting into us access to medicine
across the world to bear fruit. Therefore
I urge your leaders of the government to concern
themselves with issues that are affecting
the developing world like healthcare. We should
put a lot more emphasis also of the quality
of medicines that we are delivering to this
part of the world that are (inaudible) like
diseases . I think that is of fundamental
important at this age.